[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de pata
pêche ne faut trop d'écho comptait bien
sur vos doigts
été aux avant postes un clown attention
ils ont manqué
[Musique]
ce soir télévision très bon programme
je ne veux aucun bruit au ko l'attend
devant tu peux pas comprendre cette
attitude-là m'épate
oui si justement sûrement pas couleurs
cyan couleurs en relief alors ce soir je
m'invite je serai chez vous invitera à
[Musique]
vous en faites des têtes
vous êtes malade on a bien monsieur donc
on avait l'atelier jean collin kozlov
pour le faire enlever la crue il ajoute
pour ce soir e
[Rires]
pat un truc de pata truc j'ai trouvé ce
truc m'a appelée vision en relief ça
n'existe pas ça existera ce soir à toi
l'asus rennais ses preuves lors de
l'audition de l'amf vient voir papa et
voilà bonsoir madame monsois
mademoiselle bonsoir monsieur couleurs
relief
richard monsieur bougon et sans apport
de 6 en relief ou pas il ya toujours des
peines bonsoir madame bonsoir
mademoiselle poussoir monsieur c'est
soir notre programme commencera par une
chanson particulièrement dédiée à nos
amis les papas peluche les bataves luge
mais chez vous mu oui on est connu
abbas est gentil pour les autres que des
spectateurs
[Musique]
chapeau
on m'a beaucoup plu
oui
m
[Musique]
oh
auprès d'eux
oui c'est nous répond
pourquoi
bon
[Musique]
moi j'ai la télévision depuis plus
longtemps goût et aucune présentatrice
n'a jamais encore dédié un programme je
peux parler louis est bien mal élevés
c'est que speakerine elle est pas mal
élevés elle est très susceptible
c'est normal c'est une vedette vedette
ai jamais entendu parler de menace à la
mac est en tout cas elle est trop
maquillée trop maquillée au viennent pas
votre télévision en relief c'est trop
dangereux oh ouais m'a fait mal c'est
pas mèche
[Rires]